thank you everybody thank you for coming
um
we'll declare this meeting open on
thursday the 23rd of july
2020 for the multi-use indoor court
sports facility project steering group
um i'd just like to mention that we will
be audio screening
today so please use your microphones
thank you
now firstly we'll have apologies please
ross davidson from acom and andy coca
maycomb
and grant mcleod of staff
thank you all right someone like to move
that these apologies be
received thank you and who'd like to
second up please thank you
all those in favor please say aye
against carrick thank you
now we're going to move on to which is
um approval of the minutes for the
previous meeting which is the 25th
of june sorry um which was the 23rd of
july
someone like to move that these are a
true and correct record
i'll move thank you
all as a favor please say i any matters
arising
from the previous minutes just a couple
of updates when i'm sure that
um we have met with um arapata and he is
expecting to get back to us by the end
of august
as you know is about now so um i've got
a diary note to
contact him next week to keep that um
moving along and
i think everything else the year is
actually um
talked about in the project manager
report but i will organize
a um informally before but
with the roof going on um we will
organize
a roof ship which we've done with other
buildings we'd only just do a
five dollar pizzas from wherever um and
it looks great we'll be invited to that
but we'll probably do that when the roof
the roof is just about finished for the
main stadium now the main
indoor court part but the other roof
should be on
by around about the end of september so
i think around then when daylight saving
comes in it's probably quite a good time
because we can get a quick five o'clock
wheel of still daylight so i'll sort
that out
thank you
all right so we're going to move on now
with the architectural update please
that's fine thank you but one of the
things that
we want to discuss
[Music]
requirement for delineated
areas for sponsors signage
which has required us to make a few
minor adjustments to the
internal linings so what you see is a
series
of bulkheads set up on every other bay
on the west side and the east side
which would then accommodate um
branded signs of various sizes and the
thinking at the moment is that the west
side
would have um a full width
tier one sponsor sign which you see
there six and a half meters by 1300
roughly roughly
and then the other side would have a
similar arrangement would be divided
into two
into pairs of tier two sponsors
and we've just mocked up um local
businesses to give a sense of
what that might be um probably the main
thing was just to ensure that
rather than signs were just whacked up
willy-nilly wherever
that they were controlled and
coordinated and lined through with
various other things that are going on
in the building
such as the scoreboards and and so on
and so this has been issued to the trust
and
the wheels are turning in terms of
generating some interest together
cool so i mean the project itself will
organize the
um those bulkheads that you see just to
align through with the structural
framing
and then the signage will occur as and
when
why we need to get onto it now because
um the interior lining is starting
um the end of um into september late
september
so we need to have this not the actual
names of the signs but we need to get
the structure sorted
because they're doing the framing
otherwise it'll cost us more whereas
now it'll be cost neutral effectively
and just to reiterate all these names
are just indicative they're not
there's no reality behind any of them it
was a
place of giving a trust something to
show people to give a sense of what they
were getting
right well the question i suppose is
what kind of money will they pay but
well we've got to see what yeah
[Music]
any questions you would like to ask
anybody want to ask any questions on
this
all right thank you very much for your
reply though just
not um so what we do now is that i will
see
the um receive the
notes of this instruction would someone
like to send that please
warren and manny notes thank you all as
a favorite pci
against carrie thank you
we're going to move on then to please to
the project manager's report please
just wanted to explain a bit about the
um
main element of the report as you would
see those
and yes when the building was designed
the product was quite different what is
that
the recipes of where to dulux and
they've changed it likely so when
richard and his team were working with
us on the design of it
there was a clear coat it's got to be
fire retardant there because that
section of the building is not sprinkled
so when you get into the
um changing room inside that's all
sprinkled so you could have different
coating but in the main flight in the
main hall the main indoor court
um it's got to have a fire retardant
product the original concept was
a mixture of ply and i've got another
stepped in there chris could you mind
grabbing that coffin
to show where we're talking about is
actually on page one of the stuff we've
just been looking at
yes and i've just got this as well which
is awesome exactly
yeah so basically
we've got the grey there that's a
special product um which is
a special sound absorption product and
we've got the lighter brown
that's which is under that three meter
thing which is on this
on the under the that's was going to be
this
and the original concept of it was we
were having a white wash
finish and then the clear coat on top
because the clear coat used to have a
hard surface and it was quite boring
tough resistant with the change of
product the clear coat is not
a tough coat it's very soft so it would
get damaged and then you lose your fire
protection so it has to go on first
and then the paint has to go on outside
and the painters started
some discussions with us some time ago
about how this was going to work and
that i'm concerned about
able to finish so dulux have actually
done this themselves and
it almost looks like runs and that's not
a small button a bit of a bit you'd get
more because that's not done in a
controlled environment
so that's done and effectively just
working what would be down there
to get a controlled environment you have
to hire a spray room keep it temperature
controlled
and it's sprayed off site and then
assembled on site
and if it gets damaged of course you've
got issues and you've got issues with
maintenance down the track
and as you'll see in that report um
the additional cost to that was roughly
around that 70 000 like roughly leased
and
price it exactly because i think there's
not much point spending too much time on
negotiating an actual higher of a spray
chamber all the rest but that was the
approximate cost
so when we saw this none of us were
happy with this including these
and i must say they've been very good
with all this because they're quite
interested in the project to make it
look good
because they don't want to look bad
either so um they
had we bought to try and they tried
all this so this is the what we
basically had thought of originally but
it was dearer when we were doing the
original design
and it's called deportee and it's used
on lots of other steam so it's all
pre-finished like that
comes in very hard resistant very ball
resistant
and basically you just wash it down
so that's the what's in there now for
around 50 000
um crosstalk to get there and so that
will come and
in this effectively looking like it is
there now all those pale ones will be
the decath
and on the east wall underneath where
you saw those signs before the two the
second tier sign
right on the earth decotec as well
because that's the corridor into the
changing rooms etc
from outside it's on that well through
the
um
but it's the maintenance thing that was
concerned or the cost of getting
this to a decent finish and then the
maintenance costs on top of that
because you'll never be able to touch it
up on the site you'd have to close it
air condition it somehow
so if it's just going to be a high high
cost
so there was a problem then i talked to
chris about it um
and you know it was going to hold up the
project of awakening for the meeting
today because
that stuff was made to water so they
don't have it sitting around
and they do a shock drawing process
because they size the sheets exactly
and make them to measure so the shock
drawing process is underway and if we
hadn't
done that it was uh
last week before we started talking
about it um it meant that we would lose
about a month on the project
so you're being asked to ratify it today
if you don't ratify it we can still
there'll be a small cost because we'll
have to pay for the shock during process
which is underway
um and then we need to go back to the
pilot
so that was the main um main thrust in
that report
yes so craig the
um to see what was done in the wanaka
stadium and they're obviously very happy
with it
so that's that as well yes so how long
has that been
going for three years
oh that goes if it's been and they have
no problem with it
that's that's good i mean just to
clarify as craig mentioned
this is the product that we had
specified to begin with yes and that's
what was going to be
and then very late in the project we
wanted to make some cost savings
which this was one of them to revert
from a pre-finished board to just paint
and place board
but as it's turned out the cost saving
hasn't been in fact much of a cost
saving it's actually been
turned into complexity but if razine had
if the product had not changed the other
would have worked fine but where we have
got exposed ply
down the corridors um to the changing
rooms etc that's absolutely fine because
that doesn't need the fire retardant
clear coat
so that will still get a white wash and
a clear coat on top of it
like a varnish yeah we can just paint it
whenever we need to
whereas that is it's richard
was what we wanted originally that's
good
make sure
so that was the are there any questions
on that before i go through the report
you know the initial cost if it's if
it's expensive at the end of the day in
the long run it's the cheapest cost and
you're getting a better quality product
and i really like that combination of
that light color in the gray i think
it's going to be it's just light and
airy but smart
and it'll go really nicely with the
floor so i think it's a good feel
so i fully approve of it
good
back your decision on that i think it
makes perfect sense so
um if we need to ratify that as you're
saying then uh we should do so
thank you um there is the report you'll
have you'll have read i mean basically
the project is going
um fairly well where we are waiting for
a revised
um which i should get this week actually
a revised contract
um time schedule
program and a revised cash flow because
when we get the financial report you can
see at the moment that we look like
we're
they are not up to speed with the
contract delivery and that's because it
hasn't been adjusted for the the covered
shutdown
um but we um they are getting a revised
program done now and i went through a
bit of a draft with them
um on tuesday it's sorry thursday over
last week
and it's looking much more realistic so
it is on track um we're not running late
it just it does
so by the next financial report in um
september meeting you'll have a cash
flow that is actually you know more
accurate and then we can track it a bit
a bit better you'll also note that we
had some concerns earlier on about
um supplying the wooden flooring from
america so we've had that
confirmed now that we'll be here in
november
and we've also had it confirmed that the
um which is before we need it but that's
that's fine and we've also had a
confirmation that the
other paneling in the in the indoor
court
the insulator panel um that's arriving
on site this
next week now um and it's not needed for
the end of september so that's
that's good it's the clear you know so
we are great and glasses start to be
installed already um
so they're doing that in stages because
much easier so there's a photo of glass
windows going in now so that's
each week they'll be doing more glass so
that's all underway
and talking with the glass supply they
don't see any issues in
um keeping up with that um
and the only other thing to note in
there that's of significance is that
we are progressing the tennis resource
consent application and part of that is
just finalizing the design of the actual
layout in terms of levels etc
so we have done a slight modification to
the sway along
on the um inside the car part which
gives the pedestrian nutrients into into
tennis
and that's cost about ten thousand
dollars um but that will come off the
million dollars that the council voted
for the tennis development
right yes just while you're on the
tennis courts um is there any progress
on a pavilion
or with the with the tennis clubs and
and actually at the back of where the
tennis
pavilion may be there's another sports
field is that right or provision for
another sports field
so if you turn to page seven of our um
report
you'll see an indicative outline there
which has the pavilion and
a yellow shade there so behind that
going so cold stream road is
front and the building is at the back of
the courts and then behind that you're
right there's room for another couple of
sports fields in there eventually with
some swales
the tennis clubs are keen to progress
the whole development and they're in
frequent contact with
chris and myself um but and they are
starting to work
they would like to get church street on
the market but they have been advised
that they can't and
they won't be able to sell it subject to
a resource consent
so they are waiting for the resource
consent we're working on that at the
moment and we're getting the last
acoustic acoustic in
traffic we're expecting by end of next
week so we're hoping to be able to lodge
resource consent by mid-september
and we're already and there's also
resource concepts needed from
ecan as well because the soil removal et
cetera et cetera et cetera so that that
ecan process is underway at the moment
as well
um so that is getting progressed as
quickly as we can but the pavilion
um i got an email update from jim martin
from tennis on
tuesday and he said that they're um
commencing they've got a design done but
they're commencing work on
fundraising for that now just a thought
um because there is going to potentially
be sports
facilities at the back behind pavilion
would it be really quite
good if when it was designed that they
could have
um a two-way two-way viewing
on that pavilion so lots of glass facing
onto the tennis courts but then at the
back lots of glass facing onto the back
and maybe a um so so that it could be
multi-purpose pavilion
for different sports in the future i
think if that was the case tennis would
come to us quickly and say well
multi-use multi-pay
in terms of us contributing i think that
will come in very quickly and
i have seen that we had to get a
preliminary design done for a resource
considering
and the basic design of the building at
the moment is along the back
as it were is all the services so
there's toilets and you know um
all the restaurants so it would be a
considerable cost and there's quite a
distance between
the pavilion and proposed sports fields
because you've got a couple of swells
you've got a driveway and then on the
other side
when you actually get the sports fields
it's quite a big run also and so the
actual playing area will be quite some
distance from the
pavilion so i think at the moment the
council's already contributing um a
million dollars to the tennis
development so i suspect
but it was a good thought but i think
that's where we're at with it
thank you so what the plan is at the
moment is
on that page you'll see the blue
surfaces obviously where the tennis
courts are
that pinky reddy colour um with the
building yellow that area there
when we do the um asphalt surface
all that red area will just be left as
gravel because it's sunny to actually um
put their foot down and then dig it up
so that'll be gravel at the right height
because that's part of our ecan resource
consent at the moment we just sorted it
out this morning
because then we've got one side scrape
effectively um
which is much easier than trying to do a
separate one that could damage the other
asphalt surface so we'll do one side
scrape for the whole area
we'll get the levels about right we'll
do the tennis court
development we being the council and
then um
the red area will be left as a gravel
surface but we'll have the ducks in
there for power and
sewer and water for them to connect to
when they
when they build thank you that's good
any other questions you also see that
we're progressing the final design of
the western car park and that's the one
that adjoins the hockey car park
um so effectively is the gap between the
hockey car park and the building
so that's also on your page seven of my
report
um we're just doing that as an amendment
we've got to
when you're building car parks as part
of a building you've got to get a
building good sense we're just
progressing there's a building consider
me
i lodged it this morning just before i
came over here um
but that will actually get a good flow
from the buildings as well and our
resource concept for tennis we're
putting on that we've put an extra 40
40 something car parts i can't remember
i think it's 46 it was 43 and i think we
got three more and so i think it's 46
um car parks and we have also allowed
ducting
on the main car park um for future
ev charging stations of that eventuates
at some point in the future
excellent the ducting is there uh it's
basically
almost free to put in so so he's digging
up
very good um and we can
at some point in the future that can be
organized
if need be and happy to
answer any questions from you just a
mr clarification plea where you've got
where the trees are and just see you've
got move the tree up and
treat and tree parts so what's exactly
oh what what that is basically we were
talking about ways to delineat because
we didn't want traffic from that car
park coming out into
um yes because that is the main bus
bus route through there and drop off
zone so we didn't want there would be a
conflict of cars here
so we thought rather than try and just
do a change of service and actually move
some we had trees there
just put them more central so that's why
that move up and this is an earlier
sketch that
yeah i just had from tory but that's
that's why we moved those to make that
delineation
and also as a pedestrian barrier as well
it becomes fairly obvious it's but hard
to get through garden trees
whereas you've got a path right right
below that which which clicks in
right thank you any other questions
right did someone like to move they
report things
thank you thank you do you wish to speak
no
thank you do you wish to speak
i just want to say it's very exciting
and it's great to see the progress so
keep up the great work and long may the
weather be good so we get the roof on
right all those in favor of this uh
recommendation
oh sorry don sorry craig is the is the
flooring in there though
do we need to do anything okay
well there is a reference in there yeah
there is a reference in there what
just for a bit of background so you
understand that there is a reference in
there to the flooring what
you'll recall an earlier meeting where
we were going to put a paper or eyes to
put a paper up to council
seeing an adjustment in the in the
million dollars that the trust was going
to contribute to
reflect the credit there was going to be
for us not putting any flooring down on
the fitness centre
and fitness it includes the aerobics
room the gym etc
and that seemed a good idea at the time
um and then as we started working
through the ramifications for the
building project it becomes quite
difficult because
it's hard for leigh's to actually finish
a building with no flooring down because
for instance in the in the gym here
there's a series of floor boxes where
you don't get the levels right if you
haven't got the
and each flooring product has a slightly
different
thickness and there's no it's no big
impact there's a few mils but it makes a
big impact if the flooring box is
suddenly sticking up
and also skirting treatment and also the
sealant off the concrete because
concrete has to be sealed
different products require different
ceiling treatments
the trust has identified um a product
that they would
would like in that steps if they've done
quite a lot of work on that michael and
his team have done
quite a lot of research on that and they
would like a different product than
we had specified so what
we agree with donna is that we will
get a price and he's just finalizing the
specs of what they need
that will go to lees for a price and
that price variation will
um the broad principles and i'll come
back here to be officially agree when
i've got a price
will be that the trust will meet that
extra cost so if it is another 20 or
thirty thousand it will be dairy because
what they want we know is dearer but
the exact cost we don't know yet but it
does mean that
when we hand over the building to the
trust to operate
the fitness center in the robust room
will be ready for use yes
so the only bit that won't be ready for
use will be the spin room which is where
the primer
development is is um being painted that
will get installed later now it could be
open
by the time we actually open the
building it could be done but lee's
won't be doing that
so we're just working with primer at the
moment there's been some emails finally
think
thank you it's been a battle for
almost a year now to try and get the
actual specifications for primer so we
can get the wall linings um correct
while the wall lines are all bracing
correct so we're making progress now at
the moment
that's good thank you yes thank you very
much
um all those in favor this
recommendation be
received please say against carrick
thank you
all right financial report please
all right
really
[Music]
shove already
[Laughter]
yes
so hence why ross is down this boot
today there's now some degree of urgency
with that project
um
as i mentioned earlier the the cash flow
in here looks a little um
wrong because it looks like we're the
actual is the red and because it's
further falling behind the green but
we are quite confident that um
the project is on track and i said i've
sat down with khan and we've been
through
quite a lot of the detail and um
he's i think we're very lucky to have
him in terms of his experience in
managing large projects because he's
working in alternative ways to work that
keeps the maximum people on site so he's
progressing in different directions so
at for instance on the original program
had all the glazing going in at once
well that's a big ask for a glaze to
suddenly come and do that massive
building
so it's much easier to do that in stages
so there's been he's spent quite a lot
of time in
andy and i sat down with him quite a lot
and gone through and it all has a high
degree of logic to keep things just
moving along so it's not it a lot
different on the program than the
original one but i think it's a better
outcome
because it means some things can be
completed and also his emphasis has
also been to try and get it weather
tight as quickly as possible too
so then and because we're now the roof
is going on as we're starting lining in
the indoor courts uh we're starting the
framing for the lining on
um end of end of september so it is
going fairly well
so the the cash flow here does not
reflect
the major credits are in here in terms
of red that we've achieved but it
doesn't reflect the
additional um 50 000 that you've just
approved before
because the final figure that comes is a
line item here with a zero beside it
and that's why because we haven't
actually got a an accurate costing for
that but otherwise
i think the other big unknown we're
waiting on
is the tender results for the
construction of the
services down cold stream road so that
tenders i think it's
closed of course isn't that right yeah
so we i haven't heard the evaluation
results of that yet but
when we get that um there may be some
call on we did allow
some money for that and roster allow
contingency for that as well but we'll
just have to wait and see what that
tender price comes in
because we're trying under that tend to
the sewer and water is supposed to be
connected by the end of
the calendar year because we actually
need that to do plumbing testing
otherwise it starts to get a bit
haphazard so i think you know when i was
talking to ross
um yesterday um
you know don't see any major issues in
here
um this i mentioned earlier that the
tennis swale um that will
will go to another budget eventually um
and
and the dekatec is not not in here yet
but by next month we'll have had a
revised cash flow
and we'll know the tender outcome for
the um
the solar and water connections so we
should be in a much better position to
sort of remove some of that uncertainty
but happy to answer any questions if i
can
any questions all right i'll move that
the
financial report will be received
someone like the second that please
thank you thank you all those in favor
please say
against carrie um craig just
um thank them very much for the report
it's
um very well done
right we'll move on now for general
this is just a wee update of what the
trust has been doing
in relation to the project so
borrow one for the moment
[Music]
areas so area two is
the next page so that's our
visualization
sorry sorry page two yeah i'll let you
i'll turn this around
[Music]
so that is our visualization of what the
machines will look like in their area
too
and the glass at the end is cold stream
road if we turn the page
that is looking from cold stream road in
and that's
the running track now if we had michael
here we'd have half an hour on each page
so i'm
abridging it in my own way yeah
um so the running track so some of the
things you know we need to sort out is
that the running track goes through the
door so we need to sort of measure up
and make sure that it all fits in there
appropriately
but and in there you can see that person
standing there by those wee weights
they've got these big rack systems that
stand up
yo high so we need to make sure that
they fit in
in the cavity and we get the spacing
right and all that stuff around
and you can see around that wrap system
it's a different colored floor so they
delineate the coloring of the floor we
turn to the next page this is a gym
up in wellington that's just been set up
so that's sort of
some of the visualization that one yeah
that one's here
oh sorry sorry sorry i'd skip two pages
go back to page then
go back page to the blue one so this is
this is what we call the aerobics room
so this is the spider floor they're
looking at so people working out in that
room so that is
uh the area number four on that front
page so that's the aerobics room in
there so that's what it sort of looks
like so it's not
rubber flooring or it's not wooden
flooring it's that fibrous sort of
you know what it was i forgot to bring
the sample of snakes
only if only i was more organized the
next page
this is what one in wellington looks
like so a few photos here the next page
over is some
modern spin bikes where you sort of spin
and sort of push your arms at the same
time
a little bit weird the next one is some
rhinos
the next one you'll be impressed this is
what they call a ski erg
so you stand there and you pull those
green handles down and you ski in a
puff see you're at you all the time so
apparently they're very trendy so you
get super fit doing that because it's a
whole body
workout okay so i'll treat you all to
light up for that one
the next one the next one is some
punching bags
but these are the new modern punching
bags which are full of water
so that they're easier to to install
yes and they're easier to punch it yeah
apparently yeah yeah and so also don't
forget that like
you can pull them who's in charge here
person changes the next page over is the
lineup of the punching bags and what we
need to do
is so so these are going to be hung in
in the aerobics room if you go back to
that aerobics room picture
with a blue floor you can see at the end
of the room that's where the punching
bags are going to be hung
so we need to be able to work out you
know what structural strength we need
in the roof to hold them because the
next scheme is you then hook them up and
you hook them up out of the way when you
don't
need them because they're smaller than
the standard that's actually built now
and yes i know thinking the same thing
yeah so we know nothing about that
i know we do now that's why we're having
this seriously
any
so this is sort of uh the evolution of
design of what current
gym trends are and everything else like
that so we knew we were going to need
this stuff in here
but we haven't had access to the
detailed eagle design
to work out exactly where it was going
to do how it was going to lock until
we've done this exercise so michael is
teaming up to wellington
and being around the country searching
what sort of gear and equipment we need
what a modern germ to meet the needs of
the community is going to look like so
yes some of the stuff
news to me as well as of last week but i
go okay if that's what we need
we need to have those conversations as
to what that looks like
the conclusion of my conversation was
going to be this is why
my team would like to have some physical
access to see exactly what
that would look like and where it would
go
to make it make it all happen now if
it's going to be an alteration if we
accept that
and as a trust we accept that there may
be costs of it we're gonna have to
absorb some of that cost but
we want to make sure that when it's open
it is fit for purpose as well
it meets a need
okay right so okay so moving
on to the next page this is just a
a picture of what all those different
turfs look like
in in different facilities uh the next
page is the same
which is that one there and you'll see
there's a sort of a semi
crammer type wall up against there which
is this electronic
wall which is that one there and the
rest are just terse where you where
you're trying to get them all the same
level so everything blends in so you
there's no trip hazards or anything like
that
the next page is a visualization of
the prama that primer room and the turfs
in the aerobics room and the next page
is a more detailed version of what this
primer
looks like so those who haven't seen the
primer so that's what the primer so
it's it's basically an electronic floor
and you it lights up so
if number five is lit up it's right
through the ball to five then run down
and touch down the earth or something
like that
those circles are there do press-ups
around the circles keep up with the
lights as they go around
at the far end of that room you can see
your heart rate and they've got timers
and everything else like that
uh so it's
so that's what we're we're working
towards in that primary so that's what
it'll look like state-of-the-art
there's there's nothing else in the
country like it at this point in time
yes yes this is where i need michael
wasn't it really so this isn't just for
high level sporting activity uh as
michael said this is for all age groups
so those people with
with uh older people with dementia or
something like that when you come in
here that we can program
activities you don't have to give them
things hit the light
or do something like that and move to
the next light so it's it's really a
spread
across everybody so it's like ignite the
scale as well well but potentially you
could have a late night disco there i'm
not too sure about that
in the corner yeah yes
yes yeah so so yeah so the advantage of
it is this electronics
inevitably in five years or ten years
give us something else um well there
could be but
it will usually sorry yes and
what you provide for your gyms it
changes regularly with things like yeah
so so yes there will be something
different will this still be relevant
who knows but at the moment
this is that's a pretty relevant and
they can because they can program it and
do whatever you want to
you can set up whatever programs you
want to
at do no i don't know i couldn't tell
you specifically is it something that
could be used as a an event
or a game or yes it was team building
yes absolutely
absolutely so if we go to the next page
i'll explain that team building concept
if that's all right
so so this is a lock down from the top
so there's the prima room is the brown
around so so the concept is that that
first bit where we walked in is the
general fitness area
this area is more for uh not elite
athletes but more team training and
in those more dedicated programs we've
got those
big structure there are what they call
rigs which are big
metal frames with all sorts of weights
and pulleys and all that so carry on so
you have teams in there going around
different stations
and the same within the primary room you
can have teams in there doing different
activities around different stations and
then moving on to the next one and
everything else
themselves for training because we've
not only got this we've got we've got
the
the basketball courts and then we've got
the the sports house we've got the
meeting rooms we've got the physios and
everything else on site
okay um the next page just
is an example of
yes yes
well there's three in that video yes i
don't know that's why we sort of
you know our desire is to get on site to
say okay how many could you physically
fit in there so it's all it's
all well and good with respect craig
trying to work off plans
we are visual practical people well i
certainly
am and i go right if i'm on psycho right
how's that going so what
michael wants to get so on that top down
at the moment
those internal walls aren't up yet no
you only get the concrete slab you don't
get any feeling of where
if there's any
and then they're going to vibrate yeah
yeah
yes yeah
no it's not okay
hints i wanted to raise it to make sure
that you know the roof's not in there
and always oh well actually we're going
to now retrofit this steel beam to hang
all this punching back on
it's obviously a conversation we need to
be having now before it's too
far down the track um sorry just looking
at that that page still
that as you can see there's different
colors all around there the the rigs are
on the black and all that stuff and so
once again it's a case of
of working out the sizing where
everything
fits from a you know being on site
measuring it all up with your tape
measures before we can sort of confirm
the order
to the flooring guys say this is exactly
the layer uh
in that blue room uh and it's not
in there at the moment you know
michael's envisioned there'll be lines
in that floor for different activities
and pushing sleeves along and all that
sort of carry on
similar to some of those earlier
pictures
uh no no very infrequently like if you
go down to south broad you know that
hasn't been modified now that it's been
set up that is
you know like that ski thing three years
ago that wasn't around so you need to
find a space for that so you throw it
through something
so that the beauty of the trust is
because we have four facilities now
we the most modern gear is in south
brook and then we've slowly rolled it
around why southward because this is our
biggest market we've got to keep up with
more facilities than we do in other
areas
the the last sale taylee and charlie is
oxford
okay so they get the drinks of
everything else you know
yeah and also
sorry i mean so at the moment
up in wellington one of the gyms up here
a council run facility is being closed
up so we're
tendering for all their surplus
equipment which will roll
through the facilities and then roll
some stuff through in the high school so
we're just having negotiations with the
high school what what do they need what
would fit in their german of the gear
that we've got available
so that that's where we're sort of
working in the background all the time
um so yeah the layout is very important
one one of the questions came up you
know on the
on the eastern side there's the sliding
panels you know we need to understand
how far they are as to
where the gear fits in relation to that
you know so how far out from the wall
which is
going to determine where your power
boxes need to go and all that sort of
currency
yeah okay
but all the channels yeah no no no
that's fine i understand that but
yeah i got a lot extra put in what you
wanted yes
yeah so we extend it further to allow
for things yeah
so those plans might be originally for
electrical layout
yeah we adapted those to before yeah
yeah so i guess we're getting sort of
trying to get to the fine tuning but
before we
order the floor and finalize our
equipment order so
we're like you guys we're starting to
get to okay what equipment what's our
time frame of getting all this gear in
okay just if we flick over to the next
page
and these won't take too long this is uh
the demand from
basketball so i won't bore you silly
with it but the first line primary
school basketball won four courts for
terms one
three and four uh fridays four to nine
uh south island primary school hoops and
stars all day
so these are all the tournament star
planning on running
in there so you know there's been a lot
of interest from basketball the next
page is futsal which for those who don't
know is
like indoor soccer okay and this is what
they want they want to take
the facility for the rest of the days in
the spaces available
the next page over or they also want to
have two people in the sports house as
do basketball
the next page over is they also want to
have
uh elite coaching programs so they're
going to basically one of our coaches is
going to coach these
teams within the facility for the uh
specialist teams and all that sort of
carry on and the last page
is their triangle of what they're aiming
for so they're aiming for the
women's world cup in 2023
will be based you know or some of the
teams will be based out here so
so that's the facility they want so
basically at the moment
we can almost book out the stadium
every night of the week okay so we're
having
our last discussions
with netball who if you want to come and
play
indoors you get one last shot because
otherwise footstool
and basketball will take all the spaces
so you won't get another chance
in christchurch they're going to build
that new facility it's going to be
involved here is still focused on
dudley okay they don't
decide they want to be part of this they
will miss the chance because
futsal and basketball and then all the
other minor sports will fill that
stadium up
and they might get another chance so
we're trying to negotiate with people
to make sure
yes was always in the brief
so you know we know that then it's just
working around those sports and saying
sorry you can't come and play
this weekend yeah yeah
that uses spoken to the agreement yes
there and we would have to start at 10
o'clock at night
stadium and then
dinner was over at midnight we'd have to
pack out and by 8 o'clock the next
morning we had to be completely gone
and so that's the sort of thing that
that's working out
that's right one of those people
yeah no so that's that's just a
background of where the trust is
[Music]
thank you don that's very good yeah yeah
excellent
um can uh do you like to use the
sorry because we are live streaming
how is the trust getting along at the
moment with its fundraising
we're going fine thank you
[Music]
um uh so the
fundraising is you fully appreciate um
as caroline whitaker who we've appointed
to to
manage that it's it's what is it
boulders and then rocks and then and
then sand so our
boulders are the naming rights okay so
we've got
one party uh very interested and we're
just talking with another party so what
would
uh so i can't tell you who the first
party is but the second party is
his main main pair
okay yeah okay so we're working on the
two parties so
either they'll co-join together and
naturally we have to come back to
council
to uh discuss that further and if not
the first party is quite keen to take
the full right okay from there we've
basically got
uh three of the four courts signed up
so just one more court uh so that's that
you know that so those
big voters we've got the rocks we're now
starting to look at what the rest of it
looks like
the other issue for the trust is part of
our
commitment revolves around edward street
in the gymnastics and trampolining so
we're just working with vm trying to get
them to come up with some form of
arrangement there but you know we're
well on track
yes that's right yeah so sorry so we got
to prove
from rata foundation 300 thousand and
we've
got the application gone into lotteries
for hopefully more but
who knows so well done
yeah good thank you
anybody else any general businesses to
discuss
i'd just like to say thank you very much
for attending and
don thank you very much for your
boisterous
enthusiastic yes
we really very much appreciate it and
and the hard work that the
trust is putting into getting this this
absolutely right
is vital so thank you
has anybody got enough they wish to say
or declare the meeting closed
at 11 23 i think
and thank you very much for attending
we can better
you